la fabrique de meubles appelé les usines
réunies a fermé ses portes en 2013
la mairie a racheté ses locaux il ya
installé le conservatoire du siège et du
meuble ainsi que l'épicerie solidaire en
face depuis trois ans une entreprise
d'insertion par l'économie fabrique des
modules en bois
hélas cet ensemble par exemple qu'on a
sous les yeux c'est un ensemble qui nous
a été commandée par le département de
meurthe-et-moselle pour faire les
ateliers techniques des services route
cette entreprise est née d'un
partenariat public privé entre la mairie
et ce professionnel du bâtiment patrick
pelletier
il a imaginé les modules en bois et leur
fabrication de manière industrielle
le public a des atouts pas les mêmes que
moi moi j'en ai pas les mêmes que lui si
on les met les deux ensemble ça peut
marcher ça peut faire quelque chose tous
les morceaux bol ils ont tous le même
longueur l'iran tous dans la même
machine qui règle une fois donc ça veut
dire que quelqu'un qui en insertion va
rentrer ces bouts de bois fer sont neuf
exister dans le dans le machin participé
au montage parce que le montage il reste
simple aussi celle les enfiler les unes
dans les autres mettent des clous et si
vous voulez l'insertion
celle là elle est possible la démarche
d'insertion réussi
c'est une démarche où la personne
restaure sa capacité d'initiative
ça c'est dans l'exercice du travail des
professionnels et la démarche
d'insertion réussi c'est quand la
personne aura resterait sa capacité de
libre arbitre dans ses choix du
quotidien hors espace de l'entreprise
douze personnes ont déjà suivi ce cursus
d'insertion neuf ont retrouvé du travail
neuf auquel il faudra bientôt a ajouté
régis vallot arrivé ici il y a trois ans
j'étais en galère oui pour ça que
jusqu'à aujourd'hui le chemin que j'ai
fait j'en suis content et pour vous dire
comment idée aussi été soutenu par le
régime
aujourd'hui il a bien changé le moral la
santé quand on a du travail
sa voiture au mieux devant les bâtiments
le hamou durable projet de la mairie
ici la médiathèque 5 appartement de
plain pied pour personnes âgées et des
modules disponibles
l'un a été mise à la disposition de deux
créateurs d'entreprises et les premiers
mois on nous ont hébergés gratuitement
le temps qu'on m'ait qu'on met gentiment
la lente reprise
un conformité puis que l'écouté du
papier sauf m
ces deux anciens salariés de l'usiné de
meubles parisot ont créé brut brut une
marque de mobilier contemporain pour
particuliers entreprises et magasins ne
trêve notre volonté notre ambition
c'était vraiment de créer une marque de
meubles français et qui exploitent et
les vraies ressources locales et c'est
vrai que je fasse un loup on est au
coeur des plus belles forêts de france
on a beaucoup de chaînes feuillus il ya
des résineux en fait toute la matière
est là pour faire vraiment des produits
de qualité comme nous on souhaite le
proposer aux clients aujourd'hui on va
pas être beaucoup plus cher que des
meubles d'un port qui ont traversé la
moitié de la planète c'est que des
revendeurs qui reprennent des marges
nous on souhaite avoir une proposition
de produits direct fabricant et
on peut être compétitif sur le marché du
vrai meubles de qualité français ça
existe et c'est faire ça
oui décidément entre saint loup et le
bois l'histoire continue de s'écrire